hey hey your daddy's peeing sitting down
what do you think about that I can hear
you
for the next week I'm going to pee
sitting down and I've really sit down to
pee if a man I knew sat down to pee
every time I would think now that's a
relaxed dude you're being very trusting
with your butt cheeks when you do that a
lot of toilets just don't have a lot of
room in the front so you kind of don't
want any of you touching any of the
toilet itself it's even worse when it's
like a bar and people haven't been
aiming maybe I'd try squatting but I
don't think I'd be good at that you have
to go down no why is this toilet working
that's gross ah what's that down the
beat and
kaolinite so my initial reaction is that
peeing sitting down just makes me want
to go number two because I'm already
sitting down penis in the home is no
problem I'm not trying to pee any bars
for no I'm very mad so I wait till I got
home tonight
how'd it go I was fine any spillage no
no leaking and what did you tuck did you
tuck it in between your legs I mean it
just naturally Falls there okay I'm at a
party sitting down and I'm so scared
that someone is going to walk in the
bathroom right now and see me then I'm
going to either be like
or I'm being sit down all I'm doing is
changing from standing to sitting but
I'm sewing both on my phone and spent a
lot more time in here for that matter
maybe I figured out why don't put more
time in the bathroom I'm at a restaurant
they have assignments as Department of
stand-up operations I'm offended because
men sit - so this week I also realized
that when I'm at home I exclusively pee
sitting down so that was a breeze there
were a few times where I just refused to
sit down on a toilet because it was
disgusting and I just opted to hold my
pee and just do it when I got home
I felt because I was actually sitting to
pee I felt like I had to pee more like I
was going to bathroom or yeah I'd say I
felt kind of emasculated being sitting
down which is stupid
there's no reason but like I felt less
powerful
I like Miele sit down you know taking
the surroundings relax a little bit left
on the day it gives you a little bit
better of an insight into how females
handle having to pee out in public
places although my cats did not approve
so they were like weirded out by it
my wife approves though - loved it